Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is one of those new, absolutely insane
papers from the Google DeepMind guys.
You are going to see a followup work to an
algorithm that looks at a bunch of images
and from that, it automatically learns the
concept of birds, human faces or coral reefs,
so much so that we're able to write a new
sentence, and it will generate a new, close
to photorealistic image from this written
description.
This network is capable of creating images
that are significantly different than the
ones it has been trained on.
This already sounds like science fiction.
Completely unreal.
This work goes by the name PixelCNN.
We'll discuss a followup work to that in a
moment.
The downside of this method is that these
images are generated pixel by pixel, and many
of these pixels depend on their neighborhoods.
For instance, if I start to draw one pixel
of the beak of a bird, the neighboring pixels
have to adhere to this constraint and have
to be the continuation of the beak.
Clearly, these images have a lot of structure.
This means that we cannot do this process
in parallel, but create these new images one
pixel at a time.
This is an extremely slow and computationally
expensive process, and hence, the original
paper showed results with 32x32 and 64x64
images at most.
As we process everything sequentially, the
execution time of the algorithm scales linearly
with the number of pixels we can generate.
It is like a factory where there are a ton
of assembly lines, but only one person to
run around and operate all of them.
Here, the goal was to start generating different
regions of these images independently, but
only in cases when these pixels are not strongly
correlated.
For instance, doing this with neighbors is
a no-go.
This is possible, but extremely challenging,
and the paper contains details on how to select
these pixels and when we can pretend them
to be independent.
And now, feast your eyes upon these spectacular
results.
If we're looking for "A yellow bird with a
black head, orange eyes and an orange bill",
we're going to see much more detailed images.
The complexity of the new algorithm scales
with the number of pixels not linearly, but
in a logarithmic manner, which is basically
the equivalent of winning the jackpot in terms
of parallelization, and it often results in
a more than 100 times speedup.
This is a factory that's not run by one guy,
but one that works properly.
The lead author, Scott Reed has also published
some more amazing results on twitter as well.
In these examples, we can see the evolution
of the final image that is generated by the
network.
It is an amazing feeling to be a part of the
future.
And note that there is a ton of challenges
with the idea, this is one of those typical
cases when the idea is only the first step,
and execution is king.
Make sure to have a look at the paper for
more details.
According to our regular schedule, we try
our best to put out two videos every week.
That's eight episodes a month.
If you feel that eight of these episodes is
worth a dollar for you, please consider supporting
us on Patreon.
This way, we can create more elaborate episodes
for you.
The channel is growing at a remarkable rate,
and your support has been absolutely amazing.
I am honored to have an audience like you
Fellow Scholars.
We are quite close to hitting our next milestone.
And this milestone will be about giving back
more to the scientific community and empowering
other research projects.
I've put a link to our Patreon page with the
details in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!